you are a very nice guy thank you you're
very good at pretending sometimes to not
be a nice guy for fun
and I watch this episode like right
there I know you didn't mean that I know
you hold me in the highest regard no
idea you're my hero you're my hero
please please but anyway please that's
all over now
I'll find where that body fat is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
No you know what's funny though is that
you did an episode of crashing that I
just saw a couple days ago Pete Holmes
Oh crashing and in it you were required
you played yourself but you played you
weren't a real [ __ ] for most of the
episode and you are very very believable
oh thank you yeah I that as a small
compliment to being able to act a little
which I am not that good at so I
appreciate that other people though said
would say you're an [ __ ] too you were
an [ __ ] on the show yeah and I was
like no I
I guess you don't think I can act at all
because I was I was playing an [ __ ]
and they're like you can't play anything
you you must be an ass talking to you
this way these your imaginary con people
online they go I just saw a TV show
you're an [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's that brief yeah you weren't so nice
to Pete Holmes yeah it was a fake
scenario yeah it was the whole episode
was pretend you were very but isn't it
fun it's fun to play and I don't know if
it's an Irish Catholic thing yes I'm
always but was raised to be so nice and
when you're when your job in the in a
role or in a sketch is to be a prick
it's so liberating it's fun it looked
like you were having I bet you had a
good time I didn't have to not say some
of the things I think you know
have you ever thought like idiot at the
end of a sentence but you don't say it
like it's right over there
I didn't do that it's right over there
so it was very fun I also am very close
friends with Pete in our rapport is that
I would mercilessly make fun of him yeah
when we would go out to breakfast
especially during his divorce I would
make fun of it in a way that but - -
through humor yeah to get him over the
difficult time yes I think I should
check in if it works so he wanted to
write me as that version yeah yeah I
know exactly what you're talking about
I routinely after the late-night show I
mean I mess around a lot with our
writers and and I I like to go on these
long tirades and after after after and
then we were doing the late-night show
remember with a wardrobe room was Andy
way down the hall and a sixth floor and
that Center and I just for no reason the
it was over the show was over and I went
storming down the hall for no reason and
went into the wardrobe room and Tina
Ryan's there was one of the most
loveliest women in the world I just
started to go like this is hard
acceptable and it was just totally not
you know joking around and she knew that
she and Bruce Bromwich knew that now
Mike this is just [ __ ] you just be
like that I was going completely like
that when the guest who was Jenny
McCarthy walked by with her I think
boyfriend manager her husband manager at
the time and they peered in at us I
gotcha and I looked and I started to go
no this is just a-- and they scurried
away
I know I know that she has probably told
many people he is the worst he was
screaming at the top of his lungs out of
control she probably blames the measles
vaccine
look at this guy over here the headlines
like all nice people I think the three
of us are actually not nice that's